[Music]
our finishing is the end of the line of
the process and basically it starts
obviously with the sort of a design that
Barry and maybe our department have come
up with and then it gets put through to
sculpture and then made from a TD into a
3d object and then it gets through
molding silicon and then finally it
comes up to us and we kind of
collaboratively will discuss how the
kind of the finish of the product needs
to be how they want it to be painted and
and what material is going to be used in
and from there we we go through roll
with that to be an up finishing
supervisor basically just it involves
working alongside Barry and Sarah making
sure we often have quite a big team of
people up here especially on projects
like doing the friends - making sure
everyone here knows what they've got to
do and their timeframes
everyone here is employed because they
know what they're doing so I don't
necessarily have to teach or tell people
how to do their jobs is for just the
organization of it which on a project
like game of thrones' is so big that you
always need to have someone doing the
number-crunching and making sure we will
meet our deadlines I had quite an
unconventional start to being in this
industry I always came from a creative
background and studied out of school
then I went to London College of Fashion
to do an art foundation without really
knowing what I wanted to do and then
through that found 4:30 makeup and did a
two-year FDA courses done the closure
fashion and absolutely loved it and then
I went on to do another course in Los
Angeles at makeup designer II was taught
by a guy called mark sjostrom who I kind
of you know I loved his work so that was
really cool to get to work with him one
of the first projects that he worked on
was evil dead - for practical effects
it's you know really showcases what we
do in such a brilliant way and kind of
does a lot of old-school techniques
he's very dicks misled and yeah is
brilliant so on the back of my course in
Los Angeles meeting lots awesome he got
in touch with Nick government
and put my name forward to possibly go
for an interview for the deathly hallows
which at the time I couldn't even
believe that that was you know sort of
anticipated like oh yeah that would be
nice and then sure enough when I got
back to London I had a nun she set up
with Nick and him and I got to work on
the project it was about nine months
later started as one of their trainees
as a trainee I got kind of gravitated
towards they are finishing side of
things which is really lucky for me and
being a painter and we got to work on
some characters Grayback being probably
one of the biggest characters that we
all had to work on on that and the
Goblin sequence which having those 60
goblins and all painted hair punched and
their unapplied so that was really
fantastic opportunity and I was a
trainee on that for about 18 months and
and yet got to meet a lot of makeup
designers very being one of them and I
got worked with Barry on a few other
projects along the line behind lady 47
Ronin and we always just worked as
colleagues but obviously how is it that
so his work it was always fantastic and
then Game of Thrones came and him and
Sarah got got that and then I started
working for them so three and a half
years ago working on game of frames is
fantastic because it's such a diverse
project we get to do all sorts of things
like you know blood gags and bodies as
well as doing fantasy creatures and
aiding makeups and I've got to work on
lots of different things over the three
or four seasons that we've done now
probably for me that the biggest one was
the children of the forest we did a
character called leaf and the silicon
and painters that was a massive task for
us to do and it was a full-body silicone
prosthetic and each day it's a brand new
piece put on and a lot of hair work and
and actually I got to go all the way
with it and apply it that was five of us
applying that makeup and that was
fantastic to get to see it through all
the way a full body makeup as you know
like the children's forest that was in a
tower application so it was
eight hours before cameras and turned
over and then we would do probably
another eight hours on top of that and
then the D rig was another hour so the
days for you know our data very long
when we were doing those makeups but it
looks so fantastic that you kind of
stand back afterwards and you think it
is worth it
because I only got into the industry
sort of ten years ago and silicon was
was already you know widely being used
when we were at college we were kind of
taught foam latex and so it was actually
really really amazing to break out of
college and start using these you know
phantom materials that we'd only kind of
heard of and never never got to play
with silicon is definitely my favorite
material to paint it's got a beautiful
opacity to it it kind of really moves
and looks a lot like skin and so I guess
in a degree 2 degree our job is made a
lot easier because of the material and
painting foam is equally just as fun but
it's a completely different technique
you have to kind of put in the
translucency whereas with silicon it's
already there
so you're building up the opacities is
the polar opposite I love working with
both both the prosthetics I definitely
think that silicon just moves a lot
nicer I think do your research you know
there's there's so many colleges out
there now it's kind of making sure that
that you choose the right one and I was
so lucky that when I did my course I was
taught by a practicing makeup artist and
I think that's that's really important
so make sure you do your research with
regards to which college you choose I
think starting out for me it was kind of
good to not have any expectations and to
kind of go into the industry completely
blind and and and just absorb it and
learn on the job everything that you're
taught at college is really important to
begin with but ultimately it's what you
learn on the job
that sort of carries you through and
ultimately it comes down to being
creative it comes down to practice you
know you can you can't practice enough
you know painting from home
doesn't necessarily have to be anything
to do with prosthetics life drawings
anything like that just to keep you
practice with with our um it's just
experience in years and and just
learning from other people everyone has
there's no right or wrong way basically
and what we do and it's forever
developing and it's kind of just keeping
watching other people and seeing how
they how they work
you never ever stop learning and I think
without with that it keeps the job super
exciting all the time and you'll I will
I don't feel like it ever in my career
I'll ever be you know top top top know
everything is forever evolving you may
never give up it's a it's a really tough
industry to get into that hard work and
persistence definitely pays off and you
know going to these trade shows like I'm
apps and um a that they they host in
London and in fact all over the world
you get to meet everyone at those shows
and just going out there with your
portfolio just to showing people what
you can do and you know you should be
lucky enough to to get a job in the
industry if you keep assistant what I
love the most about my job is probably
kind of seeing things through from the
workshop all the way through onto set
it's also the team aspects I love
working as part of the team and
especially you know collaboratively from
design to sculpture the holes the whole
process and its really is really
exciting to be a part of that and when
we get to travel as well we will go out
together the camaraderie that comes with
it is it's just brilliant we all get on
so well working on a film like Harry
Potter it was sort of pinch me you know
couldn't believe I've been so lucky and
watching the films back you know my mum
and dad is you know real proud moment
for them as well and so yeah I just I
consider myself really really lucky
[Music]
[Music]